how about the texans offense
deandre hopkins gone and i don't know if
you saw the tweet last night he tweeted
at 12 17 a.m eastern time one word
grateful and he got called out for it
because people think he's showing
throwing shade or showing thread against
the texans but it's because he was on
the fallon show that's what he explained
but why not say grateful for being on
with jimmy fallon or something like that
it was enough to create sure the the
reaction that may at some level have
been intended but without him they had
to pivot to the likes of david johnson
who had a decent night sure and what is
kind of a rebirth for him
77 yards rushing 32 yards receiving my
math skills are not great but that is
more than 100 yards from scrimmage and a
touchdown early on for david johnson so
a good showing from him he looked a lot
like the guy who was a star
for a relatively brief period of time in
arizona chris yeah he did
you could see what you know he can bring
to the offense what billy o'brien likes
about him that's that first touchdown
run that was a special run you know for
a guy his size you could see he can
start and stop on a dime too got great
body control and had enough speed to run
around the edge and you know like like
edward zelaire we didn't really see him
unleashed in the past game either i know
he had the two receptions or maybe it
was more than that it was three sorry
but yeah i think this texans offense
with david johnson no deandre hopkins
you know the new wide receivers all that
hey it's a work in progress and
certainly last night was you know it was
tough sledding they they kind of had
that one drive and then just fell apart
and did nothing for a while
the thing that i worry about though just
after watching the game last night mike
i mean the offensive line was
disappointing to me for houston that was
disappointing they got their butts
whooped up front i mean watson was under
duress the whole time and i thought that
might have been something we could say
hey they figured this is always under
the rest the whole time he's always
under arrest the whole time i i had hope
because of the two rookies from last
year the way they played and everything
like that that they might have had these
problems figured out with laramie tunzel
in the center and everything like that
but you saw the right guard was a weak
point and the chief's got some some
dudes over on the other side that can
cause havoc
you're not gonna face chris jones every
week no you're not so maybe your
offensive line is better and maybe your
offensive line would have done a better
job against chris jones in november not
the first game out of the shoot let me
let me run this by you tell me whether
or not you agree with this not not that
not that i need
to invite you to disagree with me it
felt like the texans were playing a
preseason game and the chiefs were
playing a regular season game i i
understand what you're saying by that i
felt like the play call and the play
sheet with for andy reid was in regular
season mode and the texans were still in
like
hey we don't want to mess anything up
these are the basics of our playbook
we're not far enough into training camp
yet to get some of the other things so i
totally feel you i mean i thought the
offense was very basic you know very
you know yeah what i would call first
week of installation type things where i
didn't see anything where i went oh
that's a new look for them or that's
cool i've never seen them do that
and uh it seemed like that on both sides
of the ball mike that they're still kind
of in the beginning phases and
yeah kansas city looks like they're just
you know capitalizing on what they did
last year
and a point you've been making for a
while now the continuity the value of
the continuity the known commodity and
the team that doesn't have a lot of new
moving pieces and can fall back to what
it did last year because throughout
training camp think of all of the things
that a head coach has to worry about
yeah and all of the issues and all of
the concerns and all of the various
factors and that that being spread too
thin
is eventually going to manifest itself
some way and we saw it with the texans
and look bill o'brien wears both hats
coach and gm and i know he's got people
helping him but
everything that he did between july 28
and last night in his capacity as the
texans general manager took away time
that he could have spent as the coach
and it just delu i'm not look he's a
great coach and and again you know they
could have they could have drawn the
jaguars this week and won 34 to 13. yeah
that's right
that's right hey they're on their way
right so that i you know i mean of all
the teams in the nfl who drew the
toughest assignment week one it was the
texans right and you know all all we
know based upon what we saw last night
is the best possible record for the
texans can be fifteen and one and the
worst possible record for the chiefs can
be one in fifteen that's all we really
know yeah and let's remember that i mean
it's not time to throw dirt on the 2020
texans they got a tough draw right out
of the gates and they had to deal with
it and they dealt with it and they did
the best they could under the
circumstances and they learn from it
they grow from it and they try to get
ready for their next game that's the
attitude they have to have because
there's 15 more trains coming down the
track that's right you're right it's
great perspective you're exactly right i
mean it's it's yeah they could have got
the you know one of the worst teams in
football we go oh the texas looked
pretty good look at this you know oh
they're not missing deandre hopkins
you're right they did they got the worst
possible team you could deal with a team
that's just fearless and talented and
all together still so that's tough yeah
we'll see we've had this story before
with the houston texans i feel like this
is like billy o'brien's whole career
there oh i don't know they're two and
three they're one and four can they do
something what does what's gonna happen
and all of a sudden they sneak into the
playoffs so i really do have faith in
the coach and yes they got some new
moving parts that they got to work and
figure out how they want to make this
offense
uh complement each other with these new
receivers and everything like that so
they're not dead i know that not with
desean watson and billy o'brien and that
that company there i think they're gonna
be okay but i do worry about that
defense you know as you saw last night
they're just
there's too many unproven commodities in
the secondary there's a few you like but
you know jj watts not the superstar he
once was he's getting up there in age
and you see there's just no difference
makers on that texans defense and that
scares me when they have to play you
know the elite teams in the nfl that
have good offenses
a lot of coaches will split their
schedule up into 25
each four different chunks four games
four games four games four games for the
texans i haven't done a whole lot of
peaking ahead on the schedule yet this
year just because the focus has been so
much let's get to week one and let's get
through week one at the chiefs obviously
yeah then they get the mini buy and it's
the ravens my god my who who did bill
o'brien
off somebody
and then it's at the steelers and the
vikings yeah they don't get one of the
cupcakes all due respect until week five
and even then it's a brief respite
because it's the titan and packers
before you get to eat the second cupcake
out of the pack that is the jaguars so
you know this is going to be a real i
feel better about leaving the texans off
the list of players i'm not feeling
great about it
before i left them off but it's it's a
and and and that's the thing they get
some extra time to get ready for the
ravens that's the good news the ravens
are going to have seven days and the
texans have 10 days and let's see what
they do with those three days because
they're going to need every minute of
those three days to try to try to get
off the schnide as some would say and
get ready to keep rolling um so uh by
the way uh beautiful work last night by
someone in kansas city with the
assortment of cutouts not just any old
guy or schmoe like you or me chris that
was something high level
cutouts including the rock getting a
little too close to the queen i think i
look we'd have to consult with our
friends in the uk and ireland who are
watching this on sky sports that
probably is a breach of some sort of
royal call you know because chris they
tell you all the things you can say and
do and and i think leaning in like that
no her royal highness probably frowned
upon definitely she should pour a warm
cup of tea on him or something and get
him the hell out of there she she's got
her hand up there if you look at the
picture to swat him away like how dare
you i'm royalty and you're just or
waving or waving him closer could be
waving him closer he is the rock after
all maybe you're right maybe she's like
damn you're making a lot of money this
year every year now you had a big time
uh and uh
there was there was of all the other
ones up there too it was great because
you see the shot it's like oh who's that
who's that who's that of course
beautiful work to have ralphie from a
christmas story i know it's not topical
yet we're still a few months away from
christmas season but there he was decked
out with his red router carbine action
bb gun with a compass in the stock and
this thing that tells time and i know i
left some things out it's a very long
and convoluted explanation of the thing
he wanted and the thing he got for
christmas we wanted football we got
football and we've got plenty more
football to talk about but before we get
back to the actual playing of the games
we're going to take a closer look at
what went on before last night's game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports